Prince Harry and Megan Markel have said
that they will work to become
financially independent from the royal
family as they step back from their
roles in the British monarchy that has
raised a potentially awkward question
how does the royal family fund itself in
the 21st century it's not something the
royal family like to publicize but
here's what we know about their main
sources of income there's something
called the Duchy of Lancaster almost
45,000 acres of commercial agricultural
and residential properties in England
and Wales owned on behalf of a queen
the Duchy comprises around 710 million
dollars in net assets which is mostly
held in trust the profit made by these
sites castles historical land and
property at the heart of the capital
goes directly to the Queen
and no other member of the royal family
last year it netted her twenty point
seven million pounds or twenty six point
seven million dollars next up there's a
Duchy of Cornwall right the Duchy of
Lancaster the Duchy of Cornwall is a
private estate except this one is owned
on behalf of Prince Charles in 2019 the
Duchy of Cornwall paid Charles over
twenty eight million dollars on almost
1.2 billion dollars of net assets though
the profit goes directly to Charles both
Prince William and Prince Harry received
money from the Duchy through their
father last year they got around five
million pounds in total from Prince
Charles's fund there are questions where
the Harry will have to give up this
source of funding if he is to become
financially independent
then there's the family's personal
wealth that's the investments companies
and private estates that various Royals
hold the value of this and what they
yield an income is undisclosed for
instance the Queen privately owns the
Sandringham Estate how much the royal
family gains from this income is unknown
but royal biographers estimate the royal
family's wealth is in the millions not
the billions that means Royals in the
21st century might be rich but they're
not super-rich
in a move to keep this revenue stream
going but Duke and Dutchess of Sussex
Harry and Megan have applied to
trademark Sussex royal a brand which
will cover a whole host of items ranging
from sock
- greeting cards the largest source of
income for the Royals is government
money through a thing called the
sovereign grant in the 1700s the
monarchy handed over revenues from
Suede's of land to the government known
as the Crown Estate each year the
government pays a percentage of the
profits made on those assets back to the
monarchy that annual income is known as
the sovereign grant last year it
amounted to almost 107 million dollars
and it paid for royal duties and the
maintenance of palaces including
Buckingham Palace Megan and Harry don't
appear to be ready to give up all of
those funds the couple's website Sussex
royal calm so that they expect to keep
state-funded security and they want to
continue to live in a cottage owned by
the Queen and refurbished at a cost of
3.1 million dollars to the taxpayer the
fact that such a large proportion of the
royal income effectively comes from
taxpayers is part of the reason why
there is such public interest in this
decoupling the monarchy has spent years
trying to rise above such earthly
matters as how they are actually paid
for and that's one of the reasons why
the megan and harry debacle is leaving
the monarch feeling uncomfortable